and that group taking on the lefty
you saw the uh splits if you want to
call him that with the first
10 starts compared to the last five for
julio urias but
dave roberts his manager is excited to
see how aggressive he is
in tonight's game to try to get back to
how he started this season
yeah breaking ball and he struck him out
as bryant goes down
swinging two away a strikeout for
urias and a good start for the dodger
lefty
bottom of the first rolls in in la
on a saturday no score here's alec mills
who has been better as a starter than he
was kind of
trying to find his role in his spot out
of the bullpen this season for the cubs
that is into left field down the line
and
past bryant to the wall
that's digging for second he will hold
with a lead off double
to start the night for the dodgers one
two to muncie
is skied in the air to center mariznick
back
at the wall it's off the wall bets will
come around to score
back-to-back doubles to start the night
and the dodgers on top
here in the first runner at third nobody
out two-two pitch
is grounded right side a thing of beauty
base hit
in to score is muncie and it's
two-nothing dodgers here in the first
rbi number 40 for turner lefty orrias to
hayward
her ball hit sharply on the ground
diving stop in shallow right it's going
to be a base hit
mckenstry able to knock the ball down
the second baseman
they were pulling that sharp ground ball
off a hanging curveball and he gets
another base hit
that is in for a strike
and down is mills
for the fifth strikeout for urias
contreras is driven in 30 hitting 235
and he strikes out on a pitch up around
his neck
left side base hit turner two for two
two on two out there they go and ball
four
this is a very patient dodger lineup
they'll take their walks two in the
inning
bases are loaded for gavin lux big
chance here bases loaded 2-1 pitch he is
hit in the air to center
mariznick is right there and alec
mills walks two allows a hit but strands
three
through three the dodgers two runs five
hits anthony rizzo drives one into deep
right field it's got a chance gone
a screaming line drive home run to the
seats in right for anthony rizzo and the
cubs get on the board
it is now a 2-1 ball game that ball left
the park
in a hurry
that's into left and down for base hit
taylor doubled his first time and now
hops on the first pitch here and
singles to start the fourth this is
through that swung around defense and
into right
mckinstry is on headed to third is
taylor first and third one out
showing bun early again up and away
throw down
they got him taylor picked off
and contreras celebrates after throwing
a rocket down to
third two out wow wow
that's that's what's going to drive
managers crazy when you have potent
you know with people on the ropes and
you just
kind of lean out too far and what a
great throw by contreras
and my my my the cubs
making the plays so far one two pitch
is grounded to first off the glove of
rizzo base hit headed for
third is mckinstry
hit number seven on the year for urias
who looks frustrated
after being asked to punt and it's first
and third again no damage done and two
out
2-1 here betts grounds it right at
wisdom
he's got a good arm and fires a strike
good job by mills
into and out of trouble yet again
comes the 02. this is line to left it'll
drop in for a base hit and roll
all the way to the wall hayward around
first he's cruising the second
a lead-off double for jason hayward to
begin the fifth inning for the cubs he's
two for two
caps swings and lines one fair ball down
the right field line it'll roll all the
way to the corner
around third and coming home is hayward
he will
score ian happ delivers
a pinch hit double the other way that
brings home jason hayward 2-2 ball game
cubs and dodgers
here in the fifth
tied him up one away strikeout number 12
a new career high for
ulrius here is a rocket through the left
side
baez is on with one out here in the
sixth now one for three
one two pitch is slapped down the left
field line it
is gone for a home run
just inside the foul pole
[Applause]
i think the dodgers are saying they want
that checked
hayward was watching it all the way
[Music]
and justin turner's walking toward his
dugout saying
that needs to be reviewed but right now
it's 3-2
cubs on an opposite field home run by
jason hayward who's three for three
and has reached in each of his last
seven played appearances
well either way it was a bad breaking
ball and
now they're gonna change the call to a
foul ball but it was a hanging breaking
ball and he was
able to stay on
they didn't even need to look at the
replay
the third base umpire dj rayburn was
overruled
and now david's gonna ask him to look at
it
i don't know how you overturn it and
remember they've already overturned it
yeah
so with regard to replay it would have
to be overturned to be made a home run
you can't double stand the triple stamp
either however that goes
[Music]
this game very similar to last night's
game score
and they're gonna call the foul ball
instead he just gets a base hit red hot
is
jason and on base to start the seventh
he's reached in
seven straight plate appearances 2-1
pitch headed in
and a line drive base hit into right
pitch was up ortega
clubbed it into right field and he's on
with two down here in the seventh
so the easier rbi chance for contreras
he's driven in
30. check swing he went
and that is the inning contreras doesn't
agree bickford a nice job to come in and
get the strikeout
after the stolen base here comes
bellinger
back this week off the injured list
hamstring is healthy
fracture in his leg is healed and now
trying to go to work
high fly ball into center back
walk it off ballinger dodgers win it
3-2 a walk-off home run for cody
bellinger the first walk-off win
of the year for the dodgers who
beat the cub 3-2